my next guess is Minda and she's with a
company called fatality vitality v y tal
ity that's right if you're at home and
you're wondering Jason why do they spell
these names wrong they're faking it till
they make it they can't get the dot-coms
locked up by some domain broker and so
there is a time-honored tradition of
misspelling or creatively spelling your
domain name and yours happens to be a
dot Co a Company v y ta l ity vitality
dot Co and it's a social app for caring
period that's right okay mm-hmm what is
your what exactly exactly does that mean
is it a gratitude journal is it for
caring like I go care for my elderly
grandmother
now you're approaching it okay so if
vitality health is a social support
network for anyone with health or caring
goals mm-hmm especially caregivers
elders and patients got it yeah
so there was a company home here I was
an investor in and they would manage and
there was another one I forgot the name
of it
we had Seth on the program I forgot the
name of the company we'll look it up in
his honor
and they actually hire the health care
providers and send them to the house to
take care of people what do you do
exactly
so we're a different approach yes I can
think of it like a social media play hmm
but instead of hearing all about those
political memes and people you know
bragging about their travels people are
sharing their health and caring goals
connot yeah this seems very world
positive so instead of going on
Instagram and having FOMA or trying to
incite FOMA and other people or instead
of going on Twitter and arguing about
which terrorists are worse or which
hysterical crazy political party is
worse you go on vitality you say hey I
want to be less depressed less fat more
run a faster mile and then you support
each other basically Wow yep
so we found that when people share their
health goals they're carrying gold or
anything that really matters to them
you're twice as likely more than twice
as likely to actually achieve the future
you're creating so and I agree right now
I'm going to weight that with two of my
friends we're all fat we want to be less
fat and we talk about our fasting and we
use Kevin roses Xero app I introduced
them to it
we take screenshots of it we put it into
our iMessage group and we talk about
losing weight yep and it is magical
because I don't want to disappoint my
new friends so yeah there is something
to being in a Fitbit steps competition
or sharing your weight how do you make
money
well we're structuring it like an AE RP
like membership platform God so you
charge a subscription that's right we'll
have that and we're gonna charge for
transaction fees for connecting you with
really great organization than vendors
who can really serve whatever your
specific needs are okay that probably
won't work but the subscription will
who's my production okay it's a little
complicated to try to cut all those
deals and try to get a little bit of a
percentage from those companies and it's
very hard for a company to have multiple
revenue streams if I had to pick one you
were my sister and we're having like a
heart-to-heart talk you know taking my
investment hat off I'd say pick one that
you think you're capable of executing on
and that will be the clearest path to
victory and the other challenge I have
with your business is is it for weight
loss is it for mental health which thing
because sometimes when you try to do all
things you wind up doing nothing so I
almost feel like vitality if it was you
know just three things to start your
blood pressure you know your diabetes
your weight your sleep I don't know what
the common conditions are that you could
really nail that you could really you
know steps I don't know
but you'll figure that out what's your
big challenge right now our biggest
challenge is building our community at
the same time that we're building the
tech to support it we're still
pre-launch unlike the other folks sure
so you what you told me was a grand
vision
what I think is a better approach is to
pick one piece of the ground vision the
first step on the journey and make sure
you nail that first step because right
now there are specialists in each and
every vertical so on my phone I have all
trails which I pay for which the you
know trowels
I have zero which is a fasting app I
have Fitbit I have the Apple watch and I
have a weaving scout so I have like five
different things I've paid for
subscriptions I pay for to have come and
have fit bot Wow I've got like seven of
these and I think I pay for four of them
or or so right and you buy trying to do
all of those things will not be able to
with the screen real estate do a better
job than Kevin Rose is doing with Xero
or comm is doing with meditation the
world wants focus so I think you might
want to slow down and think about taking
out 90% of the features and keep it to
one so if you feel that you have the
most insight into anxiety and this is a
very acute problem or gratitude you know
or feelings of despair or wait how about
just leaving the hospital and just being
newly discharged and not being clear
about what services that are available
to you okay that still feels broad okay
so I would even narrow it down what is
the number one condition people leaving
from the hospital need help with because
you're talking about compliance and
drugs and all that and I know there's a
whole cohort of startups that do just
that I have been pitched on here is a
pill box that opens and closes and it's
a smart pill box and it tells the doctor
if you open and close it and that makes
the meta so there's like somebody
working on that then there was that
company that made the that I think
Amazon bought which made the pills in a
packet so you only open that one pill
packet every day they were launched at
our event they didn't invest like an 8
it they got bought for a billion dollars
I was like
so let me understand your business you
you put my daily pills in one packet as
opposed to me taking the six pills and
putting them in my mouth like that's
dumb
and turns out on the idiot like because
I didn't believe it so I think what do
you mean by discharge compliance well
I'm not talking about the hospital side
but I was a traumatic brain injury
patient with a great job great insurance
is actually three insurances because I
wasn't a cycling accident I know the
handlebars my bike oh my god and despite
all that support was an entire cycling
team with me and someone saved my life
in the team long arrived me and it was a
really serious accident I had left
parietal lobe hemorrhage oh my god yeah
and even with my wonderful family and
friends I was still not clear on what
was available to me and I've had to
schedule a tenth doctor's appointments i
defined it which doctors were the right
wants to go to I was bedridden and my
brain was damaged so it was hard for me
to coordinate all these things okay so
now I'm starting to get a better idea
because this is when you explain your
idea and you give an example we always
train people in our accelerator that
examples matter and the moral uh
straight 'iv the example the better and
you just gave the ultimate a luxury of
one because it's personal and now are
like oh you flew off the handles you
were at with your cycling team you had a
hemorrhage you were passed out and they
had to revive you so this was life or
death and so now we really understand
okay now and you also presented a
specific problem I didn't know what was
available so this gets more interesting
what should I do after a specific type
of injury and what's available well
that's a different thing and that could
be more interesting
so I mean often people have to have 20
different conversations to even answer
one of those questions yeah yeah so this
is interesting and I there are a number
of different approaches in formats to
solving problems like this one of them
that's gotten very popular is for you
know teleMed
there's a number of companies that allow
you to get prescriptions for things that
are embarrassing maybe to go to the
doctor and they'll do it virtually and
whether it's erectile dysfunction or
hair or UTI whatever there's a bunch of
these companies and what they've learned
is answering the questions twenty
questions having the doctor then give
you your viagra or you know UTI medicine
antibiotics is just more fluid and more
people will actually get help then going
to the doctor and sitting there waiting
so I wonder
that's one modality that's one technique
for handling that anotherís community
people pay for community and so a
community of people who have had brain
trauma and a community of people who are
suffering through one of the hepatitis
one of the you know cystic fibrosis have
a family member who's has that and these
are very specific things where the
medicine moves very quickly and slowly
but there's a lot going on let's say
right and there's often patient
organizations that are dedicated to this
work and understand those deeper needs
you know Finny friend Foundation in
Parkinson's is a really great example of
organizations like that who help folks
like this and so we have a whole ton of
these different kinds of patients with
specific needs what if you could bring
them all online so you've got something
now you have to productize it mm-hmm
and what are the things that you sort of
brought up as your problem is like how
do i productize i want you to look into
a new trend it's called a no code start
up no code start up we've seen a
half-dozen of them apply to the
accelerator what it is is businesspeople
designers idea people are able to hack
together something using existing tools
without ever writing a line of code so
as an example you could make a patreon
today using the patreon platform that's
ten dollars a month and you could
interview people with two microphones
like we're doing right now
and interview a doctor every week and
ask them questions or just a guest who's
suffering from let's just take brain
trauma as your one or cystic fibrosis
and you could see if you get a hundred
people to pay ten bucks a month that's
$1,000 a month that pays for all the
production you say okay does this need
to be in an app and if so what would
that look like right and some people are
doing this with Facebook groups they'll
test the Facebook group see if they can
get to critical mass there see if they
get to critical mass on a patreon see if
they can get to critical mass on a kicks
or you get the idea and then they could
start building glue between these things
so there's a company called mighty
networks mighty Bal I don't know what
they call themselves today but we tested
that is very cool software and you don't
need to write the software so you might
spend all this time in expense writing
the software and hire three developers
and spend five hundred thousand dollars
you may have done that already well I
have something to share with you guys I
actually have a staff of 30
okay we're entirely bootstrapped group
of employees and apprentices who really
care about this problem okay they care
about health and they're all coming from
people who had cataract surgery people
with because you have volunteers and
we're doing this on the weekends and
nights that's right and we have a friend
app and a back-end and they've done an
amazing job yeah so that's fantastic
that's one of the nice things that comes
with picking a vertical where there's a
lot of stake is that the the enthusiasm
yeah and the the kindness the empathy
the the caring that humans can show for
each other in the moment of need
absolutely you don't need to do
marketing the the fact that you're
listening to people and helping them is
the marketing it's gonna spread virally
so I would think about the subscription
business and if you're a few got cystic
fibrosis or you know whatever it happens
to be spending a hundred dollars a year
to be part of a community and knowing
that that pays for what we used to call
in the community days the list mom which
is a non gender-specific term hashtag
triggering gender wars list mom could be
a guy or a thay or non-binary just a
term that was used in the early days of
the internet what a list mom used to do
is manage a listserv I don't if you
remember these days oh I remember
you remember yeah and the list mom would
just make sure nobody was being a jerk
on the it's kind of an accurate cuz mom
was moms are supposed to make sure
you're not acting like a jerk so it's
kind of accurate s that was my mom's
role in Brooklyn and they would just if
somebody was acting like a jerk on a
mailing list which would ruin the
experience for everybody this is before
they had the term trolling they would
just put that person the list mom would
put them on moderated which meant when
they emailed the list their email went
into a queue the mom looked at and said
you know what that was a little bit
hostile you won't take a second shot at
it I'm gonna go ahead and delete that
one if it's really important to you go
ahead and rewrite it and I'll let you
give me a couple tips but you probably
don't want to call that person a
socialist [ __ ] in the first sentence
so let's Bob or a capitalist mother
effer like go ahead and like this one
this mom's used to do and it's why the
internet was so delightful we all had
such an amazing expectation on the
internet because we had mods I should
doubt myself as a former list mom you
were I wasn't this mom - all right
listen I'm fascinated by you Mindy Minda
I'm glad you're alive and you survive
this craziness my god yeah me too the
world is so fragile like we're so
fragile you know I made it out but I
think people really connect and feel
that fragility you know we're sparking a
community of helpers who really want to
help others yeah it's like deep good
work hey what do you know about life
post flying over the handlebars that I
don't share it with the audience you
have to think about like how you what
changed and how you look at life the one
thing what is it that you now know well
I think that is you know people are
often faced with creating something from
nothing
you know when you're have faced death I
remember looking at literally my life
falling to pieces when I saw death it
was pretty good wild and how do you
rebuild from that point when you think
you're gonna be disabled for the rest of
your life and I really thought that I
did was and my life was over but what I
found is that as long as you can
communicate in any way any kind of
communication if you can dialogue you
have everything you
need Wow yeah that's heavy